this week we've got Kalia tantrum twitch
since pension and body fluids shut down
yep
damn I said that like right the whole
thing it was really hard I was nervous
tell me what did you tell it Tantra hell
is tantrum yeah I [ __ ] up it was my
ears go you don't want to see him have a
tantrum
I hope they look like it I hope the
chatroom looks like how he dances that
would [ __ ] kill me look at Stephan
Eddie does oh yeah talking about so I
don't know what his tantrum looked like
but there are reports that he was
furious when his album came out to be
number 2 on the Billboard chart after
Tyler creator's album called Igor he's
that big time the Creator he's huge
yeah but I didn't know he was bigger
than DJ Cal that's crazy I think with
the younger audience cuz all the
features that he had I did anything
no it's cuz all the features he has on
the albums they're the entire music
industry yeah so it's like Rihanna Drake
like a big thing since he came out Tyler
yeah that is more like an underground
yeah but even as underground he was big
will do with the wait album sales are
you can get to number one like well
selling not not as many as it used to
have to be yes it seems like it's more
download so like they're counting
downloads it - OH Taylor's album debuted
at number one with 165 thousand albums
sold and then Khaled was number 2 out of
137 thousand but Khaled is really upset
because he had this partnership with
this energy drink and there was a
package that people could download his
album through that agreement and then so
they're saying that there were more than
100,000 albums that were sold through
that package but billboard is initially
agreed that they will count those
downloads and then after they
backtracked and said that those
downloads are disqualified from the
sales and so they're also arguing
there were anomalies and his figures but
he Khaled is understandably very upset
because Tyler he also like they did
count his downloads from like a similar
type of promotion so so he lost a
hundred thousand yeah here have been at
two hundred something yeah so dude
that's how they juice because people
like Madonna don't sell anymore so
that's how they juice their numbers and
make it look like somewhat okay is they
like the you go on tour right and so
you're guaranteed to have a certain
amount of people because you expect your
tour will fill this many people so they
give away the album to people who buy
the ticket so it counts as a sale so
then they [ __ ] stack the deck even
though people who are just by the door
are buying the album now but if you bite
the tour ticket putting you buy the
album like if you're gonna go see
Madonna it's because you kind of like
for me so it's a different thing though
right people listen to it like and they
want to hear the hits they want to hear
the old stuff that's why Madonna doesn't
play the new album at the at the concert
she plays like like Material Girl house
but her new album design he'd see that
that's kind of what happens right no one
likes the new stuff right yeah I'm a lot
of credit that's like [ __ ] Paul
McCartney here couple years ago and
nobody gives a [ __ ]
well we don't give a [ __ ] cuz weren't
probably not his demo but maybe his demo
but they're just a smaller no but
they're not here man it's so little it's
crazy like they're dying they're getting
older as far as people who purchase
albums go not people who attend tours
like they're given that [ __ ] we're
starting it's not hard to get gold
anymore like before it was a big thing
if your album went gold and I think it's
like a hundred thousand makes you a gold
album like you get that gold record and
all that [ __ ] and I think platinum is a
million yeah but now it's just the world
is way more connected so it's easy to
hit those numbers Kelvin is saying he's
gonna sue Billboard chart whoa and it's
like billboard has a lot of different
charts to it could be like the week's be
like number one or whatever two in what
category hip hop or something I don't
understand why people are hating on
Kelly I don't get it why they're even
calling it a tantrum cuz I mean this is
career
career nd I mean cuz if so we're talking
about this time was like damn like you
didn't do as good or his album cells are
dropping like something subconsciously
happens where you're just kind of like
oh he's dying yeah like you're just kind
of like okay he's old news like at least
for me that's what I'm starting to feel
where I'm just like I don't really care
if I see he dropped something new I'm
like hmm whatever that's almost like
let's say Mayweather has a 50 or no
fight record and then that's what he's
proud of right this is the greatest of
all time and then all of a sudden
well actually it's only 25 min node
because the other 25 were out of the
country we're not gonna count those
fights I could see why it may where they
would do it what the [ __ ] up boxing
matches up boxing America download is a
download that why don't you County you
would you think Mayweather those
agreements ball time I think
statistically people calm in responding
I don't think so not only it's just that
people are pointing this and just kind
of thinking it's funny because they're
saying he stormed into epic with an
entourage he was angry and yelling threw
a temper tantrum blaming the also-ran
album on his label Chiefs is not
understanding streaming services and
bundle deals another insider added he
was furious there was some nasty stuff
said publicly he's all about positivity
but there is a mean side to him that
people don't see he overhyped the dog
he's a human being
biggest album ever hey I got a real
scandal for you DJ colleges yelled at
people like whoa they act like the Dali
Lama came in and lucky right got all
aggressive another thing is that he was
also super upset that the label wasn't
fighting for him guys understandably
yeah I'd be pissed too I'm like I'm your
artist you're supposed to take care of
me we're in this relationship mm-hmm and
you're not backing me up that's [ __ ]
up they're too busy with the EDM section
of their department yeah that's making
them more money no I mean for them for
the labels perspective they're like well
we don't care both of our artists are at
number one and number two
so oh cause the tire is on the same
label yeah that's that Sony owns a shake
damn so he owns everything that's crazy
that is crazy you know what's even
crazier Michael Jackson estate owns like
50% of all the songs that Sony like has
and then they license it to Sony yeah
that's why they try to kill him or
that's why they killed him why
Michael Jackson what the so death is
good problem sales no no no so then the
estate manages it and then he you know
there's like a team that has all the
[ __ ] what do you call it the
conspiracy that he got killed by the
label yeah
because he'd been to a lot of people
think I never heard this okay so Michael
Jackson is a [ __ ] genius when it
comes it surprised that the conspiracy
I'm surprised that you don't know the
conspiracy so Michael Jackson is a
genius because very early on in his
career you know it's funny Paul
McCartney told him that what you got to
get into is you got to own your own
music and you got to start owning music
period that's where the money is at the
next day he bought [ __ ] Beatles one
of pieces she bought all he bought the
Beatles catalog business baby Paul
what's the matter Paul I thought you
told me to do that Paul that Michael
Jackson right now sounded like a pimp
I'm Joe it's just business baby okay so
he just bought a lot of music he owns a
lot of music right he didn't want to
release it and in you know it's he's
charging a lot of money for it and then
the conspiracy is they killed him so
then whoever holds the state like his
lawyers and all that will want to start
selling it and giving it back to Sony
and then he owned like 50% of Sony's
licensing yeah yeah so Sony doesn't like
not having control of their own music
and now there's a lot of music right now
that's being on movies and all that
stuff because it's cheaper yeah you know
it's not a scandal is that he was killed
by his doctor yep yeah for your
conspiracy theory yeah okay but on to
the next story so do you guys remember
we've talked about this really really
really really really popular twitch
streamer named doctor disrespect yeah
what is he oh yeah wasn't he handsome
it's a bit right it's character yeah so
he's like a character thing to be honest
with you I don't even remember what we
talked about on Twitch any super popular
on that we talked about him because they
shot up his house
in the middle of the livestream yield it
do the memory when he shot up case the
house week it was streaming it stream I
used to have shitty memory now I have
really [ __ ] good memory that's mom
[ __ ]
yeah well baby I have the opposite of
mommy green I forget everything dude I'm
a mom and I create everything man all
right so the mute drama here is that he
went to e3 which is the biggest there's
happen about now gigantic video game
conference and doctor disrespect he did
his first in real life livestream oh
cool and so they're saying like it was
one of the best live streams ever like
it was amazing but he [ __ ] up because
on four separate occasions he decided to
take his livestream into a public
restroom and whoa no oh he was so he was
taking a dump and stuff he was streaming
random people and at one point they're
saying that you could see a child using
a urinal
[Laughter]
you just gotta get that kid and the pet
to sign a waiver and again you're good
tiny you're a hundred percent tiny yeah
so they're saying that never live stream
you slap a piece of paper on the outside
of the bathroom it says anything in here
is chill because we're filming in there
that's what I mean what was his team
that's a and so like for example let's
say like they caught me using the
restroom and then he's like can you
please sign this and I'm like I need
twelve thousand dollars right now he has
to give it to me right well he doesn't
have to if he takes you out if he like
blurs he would blur you he saves 12
grand and blurs you but it's like yeah
and yeah you can see one myself I could
be like I need $100,000 really yes he
has more than three million followers
damn I wonder how many of that tunes in
that's crazy
that's insane what did he do he just
livestreams the there was around 60,000
people watching let's do a lot just like
light like why have you go into math are
you doing bidden air
yeah I don't know I didn't watch it
maybe it was just like a continuous
stream like he's just yeah
yeah at the coal convention or separate
times he went into the bathroom and then
so because of that twitch announced that
he's being banned can you imagine your
hair like that yeah that sucks that
sucks a lot of people a lot of popular
streamers are saying like this isn't
gonna last because he's so [ __ ] here
yeah they don't want him going to
different platform yeah I miss followers
yeah but in the meantime right now that
he has been banned other streamer
popular streamers have seen an uptick
and viewers because like his viewers
have to go somewhere
he's been hogging it all up yeah dude my
brother told me about this and I'm saw
unconnected to all this gamer world [ __ ]
and he's like hey did you hear that
doctor disrespect got banned from III
for filming in the public bathroom and
I'm like what the [ __ ] did you just say
it sounds like a different language now
you know now you're in the know yeah I
know I know I know I'm glad you told me
but sometimes you don't want to know
either you know right you don't want to
be in with hip to the coolest certain
lingo cuz and now you feel like you're
part of this icky we're knowledge is a
burden bro so so I'm currently obsessed
with you guys heard about this Star Wars
land that just opened yeah okay so you
guys know that I'm uh
I love cringe [ __ ] right [ __ ] London
Joe loves cringe [ __ ] so what the
current new cringe [ __ ] is when you go
to Star Wars land you can make a
lightsaber right that's dope it could
could have been that way
could have been dope but what happens is
you go in there and they have like a
[ __ ] ceremony and they the guys in
character and he's like you're a [ __ ]
Jedi just like Harry Potter right they
do with the wand but this is even more
critical I went to that I went to that
stood in the room watch them sell wants
to those kids right they've literally
marks the K to the front of line and
[ __ ] like the one that chooses you
they take that kid in the front register
I thought about you in Osaka because we
ended up going to Universal there and we
saw the whole thing and I think movie
wanted a wand and I'm like oh my god
Steve is watching so so in this ceremony
they're like hurry we don't have much
time they're like they're in there and
they're like like close your eyes
whatever color the saber is will come to
you and then they things like bring you
the color that you're supposed to pick
and [ __ ]
just like the cringe level is like a
[ __ ] injection into the [ __ ] and
like into a vein like I got your hit I
said to my buddy and he's like dude I
watched the whole thing and I was like
when did you grow and he's like the
whole time but he loves this [ __ ] you
know I mean so basically it's just a
sales tactic to get the kids like I need
a [ __ ] lightsaber no you already paid
$200 just to be in the wrong ceremony
yeah and they got Frank Oz doing the
[ __ ] rolling out the yo-yo to talk
while you're doing your lightsaber thing
it is [ __ ] the craziest name Wow you
see cool like adults that are super star
wars fan no fat like 35 year old man
like raising like a metal lightsaber
wand and they're like you did it you
[ __ ] are a Jedi now and these fat
dudes with fanny packs are like yeah I
know saber crews I've seen them
I saw a [ __ ] swarm of them like
battling it out at the park yeah we
personally know yeah and they do like
lightsaber duels and yeah yeah I gotta
go to this yeah because I went to your
karate thing and that was that was
actually just no well there was one
funny guy one funny guy who took it
really seriously but then everyone else
is pretty good but what lightsaber [ __ ]
is everyone take it seriously and oh
yeah yeah well what do you think those
people do in their everyday life when
they don't have their lightsabers Oh
jerk off oh my god moving on to our last
story here this one's kind of gross Oh
like in Connecticut there's this Thai
restaurant that is on the first floor of
a building that looks like this what's
gross it's very kinetic you're looking
here is the restaurant looks very clean
so someone living in this in this
building here they noticed that they
hadn't seen one of their neighbors for
quite some time they ate him so they
were like damn you know like we should
call the cops we haven't seen this guy
in a while and also the the Thai people
they saw they noticed that there was
like the leak on the roof they're like
what the [ __ ] and it was leaking right
behind the counter so then when the cops
went to go check these party disco post
exactly on top of our restaurant yep
holy [ __ ] was falling on customers
behind the counter Oh imagine if it was
falling on your food yeah you guys are
probably eating I would so they're
saying that the owner of India brought
nearby barber shop said they hadn't seen
that neighbor for at least six days so
that's when when when the cops showed up
they were met with really really
discussing me foul odor and there was
just this like really weird liquid
happening oh my god that was leaking oh
gosh I want to smell dead human No
everyone says it's like the worst smell
that they've ever like smelled you
should have more no yeah I'm an original
smell yeah like I yeah yeah cuz I'm kind
of interested too
that's what everyone says what why just
so I know what I smell amazing one wants
to hold your dick what do you mean one
yeah right good point
no it is sometimes Nikki like pull
something out of the fridge and she's
like she's like oh god smell this and
I'm like no why I want to know yeah you
want to add it to your databank so
you're like you want to know what it is
really one time and then you're done
it's like getting a new color in the
crayon box like sometimes not gonna use
that Bailey oh that color exists yeah
curse all dirty fridge stuff it's like
probably like mold or something you know
every day and every week and every month
that the body decomposes it's like it
goes into different stages and gets
worse you get you learned visit the body
thing we're at I forgot where I saw this
but I remember watching a video and
there was this person explaining where
they work and they work in this really
huge space that they intentionally you
know when you die and like you decide to
donate your body to science
oh yeah they use these bodies and they
put them in different locations to study
how the body decomposes in different
environments if we're like different
increments of time it makes sense like a
human body or a [ __ ] cold but are you
sign up for that you're like hey I want
to donate my body to science but I want
my body to be pretty disrespected right
and that's I was gonna say cuz I always
thought about donating it but if that's
what they're gonna do with it some
people do for your organ donor
relations I am I am too and I tried
removing it waiting for moving Ferguson
I'm not our me neither
these are mine no [ __ ] take them all
don't you think in the back of your mind
aren't you like oh [ __ ]
what if I'm I'm gonna make it but
they're like oh there's some sick organs
here oh yeah for sure
well then there's I forgot the other
method but you have to be either brain
dead or something else but your body has
to still work and if your organ donor
that's when you can give a tip how many
times have you heard of a story or we're
done on janky news where it's like a guy
was dead and he's at the morgue and then
the guys about to work on him and then
he wakes up I'm like who's declaring me
brain dead bro some [ __ ] college kid
I'm gonna wake up when it's the time I'm
not sure what you said I agree with you
that's our entirety the the [ __ ]
relationship but I agree with you dead I
don't see ya [ __ ] I gotta live from
steam hotter percent agreed what
happened but yes so the restaurant here
they temporarily closed obviously
because they're saying that because of
the fact that the the fluid was dripping
into the restaurant that means that
their ceiling wasn't up to code
oh wait so eventually when the body
decomposes does it turn to like a liquid
and musty and just like sticky stuff I
guess that's a tough question
I guess though I I know that all of our
liquids go out when we die like Kaka
peepee poo-poo yeah goodbye just relax
bloated your body like get the gas we
gotta do have you guys seen rabbit fur
turn into maggots so I had I had like a
little like lucky like not like rabbit's
foot it's like a fur thing I forgot
where I got it from and then I put it in
a jar and I put some water in it and I
sealed it cuz when you're a kid you
don't know that it's not water it's like
formaldehyde or something like that you
know so I just wanted to do when I saw
in the movies so I put it in there and I
sealed it with water and I put on my
backyard and then every day I would go
out and look at it and then so it was
just soaking and then after like a
couple weeks it starts to sit or a
couple days starts disintegrating and
then it
turn into like this mush then you'd see
all these bubbles like it's trying to
leave the thing and then I don't know
where all these maggots started forming
and I've never opened it once do you
think that your parents were watching
you through the side door and doing this
every day going outside looking at your
little jar with your [ __ ] rabbit's
foot submerged in water and they're
going oh we have such a normal son they
were the ones putting this [ __ ] like the
mold and the maggots cuz I'm thinking
like what of maggots create I don't know
how do they form in like no oxygen
you're such a curious kid too like for
you to do all that we know only child
you gotta entertain yourself an only
child but I just watch TV all my people
is taped up that's why no it was like so
my mom with yours makes more sense yeah
right no my mom would get a paper and
she would tape it up and then when she
comes home shall I touch the TV see if
it's warm and see if I appealed it ah
that's holy [ __ ] yeah so if I watch TV
should beat the [ __ ] himself
she didn't [ __ ] see us I job to see
if you watch TV yeah I should get the
[ __ ] out of me you know what it actually
helped you out a lot because look how
intelligent you may be huh huh they
[ __ ] up to you you're very creative I
don't know you see we just do a Twitter
poll
[Laughter]
[Music]